hey thanks for checking out this video
we're going to cover the basics of sass
and then we'll create a project from
scratch and deploy it and I'll show you
how you can easily include sass in your
workflow and I want to give a big thanks
to Bo and free code camp torque for
publishing this video free code camp is
an awesome resource and on behalf of the
community thank you for all that you do
so before we get into this video I'd
like to quickly let you know who I am
I'm a husband a father and a programmer
I've got over two decades of IT
experience
I'm a full-stack developer I recently
decided to create a YouTube channel and
initially I just wanted to help people
but after my first couple of videos I
realized that it's actually helping me
to become a better programmer I do
research for every video and a lot of
times I come across things that I didn't
know or a better way of doing things so
I'm learning and teaching at the same
time so win-win so my channel is new but
I upload new videos every week I'd
greatly appreciate it if you check out
my channel and subscribe and that's
enough of this let's get into the video
so we're going to go over the basics of
sass and set up our environment and then
we'll go through a project from
beginning to end using sass there's time
stamps in the description if you'd like
to skip through certain parts so what is
sass
it's a CSS extension language and gives
your CSS superpowers once you see how
easy it is to write and how logical and
organized it can be you'll never write
plain CSS again you'll see what I mean
in a minute let's look at what you need
to write CSS first you'll need a code
editor and I recommend vs code because
it's open-source and has great
extensions and awesome community support
now your browser can't read sass so it
has to be compiled into plain CSS but
don't let that scare you it's easy there
are several ways that we could go about
this we could use nodejs to run a
compiler that will watch our sass files
and compile them automatically for us or
we could use gulp to do the same thing
or we could use an extension in vs code
and for this video that's what we're
going to do we're going to use live sass
compiler another extension that we're
going to use is live server if you're
unfamiliar with vs code and how to set
it up for web development I do have a
video on that I'll have a link in the
description
below all right I'm going to quickly
walk you through installing the live SAS
extension so in vs code we'll go to
extensions and we will search for live
SAS and there you'll see live SAS
compiler go ahead and click on that and
then click install and after that's
installed we're going to look at some
settings so let's go to our settings and
then we'll search for SAS
and then click on live SAS compiler
there and then you'll see in the format
settings we're going to want to change
the save location now these settings are
a personal preference by default it will
compile your CSS and put it into the
same directory and I prefer for the
compiled file to go into my distribution
folder so we'll click on edit in
settings JSON and then here we're going
to add some settings
so these are your options so the default
is at the top here format is expanded so
there's no compression going on the
extension name is dot CSS and then the
safe path is null so that means it's
going to go into the same directory as
your sass files so you can also change
the format to compressed if you want and
it will go ahead and compress and minify
your CSS all in one shot and then you
can change the extension name to min CSS
and then you see with err where we can
put it into our distribution folder so
I'm actually going to do just a
combination of the two for this video
and we're going to keep the format and
expanded and the extension as dot CSS
and we're just going to change the safe
path to slash dist slash CSS and then
we'll save that and we're good to go
all right now that we have all of that
set up let's create a standard folder
structure here so I have a new project
folder that I've created and I opened it
in vs code and let's go ahead and create
a folder here called dist
and then within our distal der we'll
create an HTML file index.html we will
use Emmet when we use exclamation enter
get a template here and we'll just name
this sass tutorial that will add link
here to our CSS so currently we don't
have one but we will be adding it notice
the extension here is CSS not sass or s
CSS so this CSS file is what's going to
be compiled eventually once we've
created our sass file now before we
create our sass files it's important to
understand that there are two syntaxes
supported by sass so there's the S CSS
syntax and it uses the file extension s
CSS and this stands for sassy CSS
it's basically a superset of CSS which
means essentially that all valid CSS is
valid s CSS as well I'll show you that
in a minute but because of this
similarity it's the easiest syntax to
get used to and the most popular now the
other syntax is the indented syntax and
this was the original syntax for sass
and it uses a file extension dot s a SS
the indented syntax supports all of the
same features as s CSS but it uses
indentation instead of curly braces and
semicolons there are a few other minor
differences but we're not going to be
using SI SS in this video so we're not
going to go over those alright so we'll
be using the S CSS syntax and so let's
go ahead and create that structure so be
sure you're in the root of your project
and go ahead and create another folder
here and we're going to name this s CSS
and then within here we're going to
create a
main scss alright now that we have that
file open we've got our extension
installed so now you should see this
watch SAS at the bottom so go ahead and
click on that and you're going to see an
output here you'll see here that it's
watching for our SAS files now and it is
compiling and generating them
automatically and now it's watching for
us to save the file again and when we
save it it's going to automatically
recompile and create that CSS file every
single time that we save the document so
we didn't add this CSS folder here but
now we have a folder in dist
and so that extension created the folder
and it created our CSS file and of
course we don't have anything in our SAS
file and so I don't expect to have
anything in our CSS file either
so remember we said that any valid CSS
is also valid sass so let me show you
what I mean by that so here in our sass
file we can add let's just do something
generic here we'll say body background
and we'll set it to blue and I'll hit
save and it automatically compiled our
CSS for us so now if we go to the CSS
file
we'll see body background blue just the
same as we see it here so we can write
plain CSS in our sass file and it will
work just fine so I also have a live
server installed so I'm going to go
ahead and hit that go live and here you
see we have a blue website so an
important note here is that we should
never modify the CSS file only modify
the s CSS file every time the compiler
runs is going to overwrite the CSS file
so the first sass feature that we're
going to look at is variables now you
might say CSS has variables too and
that's true CSS does have variables now
but sass has had variables long before
CSS currently CSS variables
compatibility across browsers is about
90% so that's pretty good and I don't
see any reason not to use CSS variables
but when you use sass variables they
don't compile into CSS variables they
compile to the actual value so let me
show you what I mean there so in normal
CSS we could add variables like this so
now we could set our background here
using a CSS variable just like that and
so now if I save this you'll see that
our CSS file is pretty much identical to
the s CSS file and if we switch over to
our website we now have a gray
background so now let me show you the
difference between this and the sass
variables so with sass we can
get rid of the root and instead of the
dashes we'll add in a dollar sign so a
dollar sign indicates that it is a
variable so instead of calling the bar
we will just input the variable and I'll
save this we'll switch over to our
website and it's still great and let's
look at our CSS now we don't have any
variables defined it puts the actual
value there so using SAS variables has
100% compatibility across browsers
alright next let's talk about maps so if
you're familiar with JavaScript you
could compare maps to arrays maps are
lists of key value pairs so I'll create
one here so we'll define a variable and
we'll name it font weights and then to
define a map we start with parentheses
so answer a key so we'll say regular
will be the key and then the value will
be 400 will enter another one we
separate these by commas
so we'll say medium will be 500 and then
bold will be 700 it's probably not the
best example but you can create a map of
colors or different things so that we
have something to really add this to
let's put some HTML markup in here so
we'll add a div with the class of main
and then we will put a paragraph and
we'll just put some warm in here 50
all right it's now in the body we could
apply font-weight globally if we wanted
to get a value out of the map we'll use
map get all right and so it's looking
for the map and that would be font
weights and then the key would be lets
say bold so this may seem like a bit
much but if we have our font weights
defined throughout our CSS and many
different areas and for some reason we
want to change the way that the normal
medium or bold font looks let's say we
want bold to actually be nine hundred
instead of seven hundred I can change it
in this one spot instead of searching
through all of my CSS and changing it on
each individual line now before I save
this let me pull up the website now and
our text we forgot a text color let's
apply our color and we'll set that to
text color now we see that everything is
in bold so this looks at our map and we
tell it which key to look for it finds
the key and then it extracts the value
and it puts the value here as font
weight so go to CSS will see that our
font weight is set to 700 right next
let's talk about nesting so nesting
might be one of the best features of
sass but depending on how big your
project is be careful with too much
nesting using classes that can be reused
instead of nest after nest is much
better but to demonstrate nesting we
will look at our paragraph here so we
have give the class of main in a
paragraph
so let's look at the main dev first
let's say that we want to Center it and
add some margin on the side so well so
we'll set the width here to 80% and
we'll set margin top and bottom to zero
left and right to auto and this is just
plain CSS so if we go here we'll see now
it's centered and we've got some margin
on the sides all right so now if we
wanted to style our paragraph normally
we would have to do main and then
paragraph and do it like this or we
could just do paragraph and that would
globally change all of the paragraphs
but we don't want to do that with sass
we can nest
so within main we could just do this and
let's say we just want to put that font
weight only on this paragraph we'll move
it down here and I'll save that switch
and we'll see the same thing nothing has
changed and if we go to our CSS you'll
see that it has written it as proper CSS
so that the browser can parse it now if
we want to do this properly let's add a
class here to the paragraph will set it
to main paragraph and then so instead of
targeting the tag directly we could do
main paragraph
I save that now it compiles properly
into CSS but with sass we have some
shortcuts so instead of typing main
again we could take this part out and we
can use in amperes and so amperes an
equals the parent all right so let me
save that and go to our CSS now it's not
quite right because it's main underscore
paragraph on its own not within the main
parent so to fix that we actually have
to use something called interpolation
and what that means is we don't want
just dot main paragraph we want
everything before it so we have to wrap
the ampersand in hashtag curly braces
and so now what we could do is add a
hover on the paragraph and so we want to
add that on the paragraph not main so
we'll nest that again and this time
we'll use just one amperes an and we'll
use : hover like we would normally and
then let's just change the color to pink
all right and now I'll save this and if
we go to our website and we hover over
it now it's pink alright let's look at
our CSS let's see what happened here so
we've got everything separated as it
should be in CSS now so let's talk about
separating files so with sass we can
create partial sass files that contain
little snippets of CSS that you could
include in other sass files so if we're
working on a large project it's a great
way to modularize your CSS and make
things easier to maintain a partial is
simply a sass file named with a leading
underscore so the underscore lets sass
know that the file is only a partial and
that it should not generate a CSS file
so the compiler is going to ignore those
files that begin with an under
or so let's create a partial here make
sure that you're in your scss folder and
we'll create a new file and we're going
to name it underscore resets dot s CSS
all right now in this resets file we're
just going to include our normal resets
so we will do a box sizing of border box
margin zero and padding of zero all
right just some normal resets there I'm
going to save that and then in our main
s CSS we'll want to include them at the
top here because generally will have our
resets at the top and so to include that
we will use in at import and then we
will indicate the name so notice here
that we don't have to put the underscore
or the extension so now if I save this
and we look at our main CSS it has
compiled our resets into our main CSS
from the partial and also notice that
the vendor prefixes are automatically
added by the compiler so what we could
also do is we could create another file
here and we could name it underscore
variables dot s CSS and then in our
variables we could take all of these and
we'll put them into our variables
partial and I'll save that and then I'm
going to use alt shift down arrow to
duplicate that and we'll include our
variables so now if I save that you'll
see that the variables are still working
so by using partials we could separate
major components into partials and this
is especially helpful when working with
a team on large projects we can break up
the components and work on them
individually all right so now let's talk
about functions so if you're familiar
javascript functions and SAS are very
similar so to create a function we'll
put it here at the top and I'm going to
say at function to define that this is a
function and then we will name it
so this this map get and the font
weights down here it's a bit much it's
kind of ugly we can shorten that up
especially if we're going to be using it
all over our CSS so we're going to
create a function that is called weight
and then we're going to open parentheses
and we're going to put an argument in
here we're going to put a variable of
weight name and then we're going to open
it with curly braces and within the
function we're going to return and we're
going to use map get and we're going to
target the font weights and the key is
going to be our weights name so this
variable here is one of you passed
within our SAS file whenever we call it
so instead of map get down here we're
going to use the function name weight
and within that we'll pass it the weight
name that we're looking for and if we
change this to regular it would return
the regular weight so let me save this
and we'll go to our CSS now we're
looking for the font weight let's see
what it what it is
font weight of 400 right so that's our
regular font if I go back here and
change it back to bold and we check our
compiled CSS now it's 700 all right now
we'll move on to mix ins and so mix ins
are similar to functions so to
demonstrate this let's add some more
HTML markup so I'm going to just
duplicate this this paragraph here when
you use alt shift down arrow create
another paragraph
and I'm going to save that then back in
our SAS file in the main here let's say
we want to display this as flex and we
want to justify the content center and
align items
Center if you haven't learned CSS
flexbox and CSS grid I have videos on
those as well I'll put links in the
description below let me save this and
let's switch over to our website and we
see now that our paragraphs are side by
side because we define them as flex so
by default that is going to flex to a
row go back to our code here and let's
just say that we have many of these Flex
boxes that we need to create and we
don't want to type display flex and
justify content and the line items a
million times so we'll go up here and
we're going to create a mix in so at
symbol mix in and we're going to name
this and we'll name it Flex Center and
then within Flex Center we're going to
put all of this content that we don't
want to repeatedly type and now within
main instead of typing all of that we
will include the mixin so @include and
then flex enter just like that now I'll
save that and let's check out our CSS
and in our main we've got all of our
flex and again it's added all of the
vendor prefixes as well now similar to
functions we could also pass an argument
into the mixin so let's say we want to
pass it direction and then we could
define flex direction as direction so
now instead of including Flex Center
we're going to also include an argument
here and by default it is a row so let's
let's define it as column and I'm going
to save that and let's go back to our
website and
you'll see that they are in a column and
not a row and of course if I change this
to row and save it and now you'll see
they're in a row alright so mix-ins and
functions are very similar but just
remember that functions should be used
to compute values and return values
mix-ins should define styles another
example of a mixin is choosing between a
light and dark theme so by default right
now our website is a dark theme so we
could add a mix in and we'll name it
theme and we're going to pass it a
boolean value so we can assign boolean
values to variables so we will say light
theme and by default we're going to set
it to true so now again if you're
familiar with JavaScript we can in SAS
we can use if statements so we're gonna
say if light theme so that means if
light theme is true then we're going to
set background now currently background
is set to primary color but what we're
going to do is we're going to wrap this
in a light and and then we can tell it
how much delight in it by we're gonna
say a hundred percent so it's basically
going to invert the color and then we
will need to set the color as well
currently that's set to the text color
the text color is white by default so
we're going to need to do the opposite
so we're going to darken the text color
and we're going to do that by 100%
all right so now to use this we're going
to create a let's go down here at the
bottom and we're going to create a light
class
and we're going to include our theme and
we're going to pass it that variable so
light theme true I don't have to
actually type this light theme I could
just say true this makes it a little bit
more identifiable all right so let's
save this and now we need to add this
class somewhere so let's just let's just
add it to the body for now class of
light save that and now let's go to our
website now we have a light theme and so
now if we change this to false let's see
what happens it's still a dark theme
even though we have the class of lights
on body it's still a dark theme how is
that possible so let's look at our main
CSS we've got our body here the remain
all of our main paragraphs but there's
no light theme here go back to our CSS
and we've got it included here
well we've included the theme and we've
said false so if we go up here to theme
so if it's true it's going to add these
CSS styles to the light class if it's
false it's not going to add anything so
that means the light class is empty so
when the compiler runs if it finds a
definition that's empty it's just not
going to include it in the CSS at all
all right so if I go back here and I
change this back to true let's look at
the compiled CSS and now we have our
light class all right back at our main
sass file
mix-ins are pretty cool so I'm going to
show you one more mix in this one has to
do with media queries so we're going to
create a mix in and we're going to call
it mobile and then we're going to use a
media query so just a normal CSS media
query we're going to say max width of
let's just say 800 pixels
and then in here we want to include
content so this content will be passed
when the mixing is called
now what we also could do instead of
defining this this width here we could
actually use a variable and it would be
better to use a variable because if we
ever wanted to change it would be easy
to change so we're going to create a
variable here called mobile and we will
just set that to 800 pixels and then
back here in our sass file instead of
putting the value there of 800 pixels
we'll just include the mobile variable
all right so now let's see you know what
did I miss here content there we go
now to include this let's say if the
width gets below 800 pixels we're going
to want that to change to a column all
right so here within main so here we're
going to include our mix in some include
and then that is going to be mobile and
then within this basically view this as
your media query so what do you want it
to do when it's below 800 pixels so
we're going to say Flex Direction column
alright let me save that and I'll switch
to the website all right so let's make
this smaller and there you go
once we get below 800 pixels it changes
to a column alright and then move it
back over it's back to a row alright and
then if we ever need to change the
widths we have the variables here where
we can change our widths all right so
now let's talk about extensions so we
can extend an element and so the element
that we extend it to would then inherit
all the styles from the selected element
so to demonstrate that let's go to our
HTML
change the classes to paragraph 1 and
paragraph 2 all right so now here we
will change this to paragraph 1 and so
let's say that we want to extend all of
the styles of paragraph 1 on to
paragraph 2 we want them to look the
same but we just want to change one or
two things on paragraph 2 and we don't
want to have to retype all of the styles
on both paragraphs so we could do this
we have to interpolate again the
ampersand and then we'll do a paragraph
two and then here we could extend main
paragraph 1 and we'll save that switch
and now they're both identical just as
they were before but now we want to make
a change to this paragraph so we've
extended all of the same properties but
let's say we want to will use hover
again and this time we'll change the
color to our accent color all right
and so now we have our accent color so
if there was a bunch of styles here in
paragraph 1 and we didn't want to retype
everything we could just extend from
that class on to this class the last
thing that we're going to look at is
operations so addition subtraction
multiplication division so a normal CSS
we could do calc and then I don't know
why we'd want to do this but if for some
reason we wanted to subtract 40% that
would work just fine but in SAS we don't
need the calculation
and it will work just like this
we'll hit save go back and just the same
now one thing to note with the normal
CSS calculation I could do minus 400
pixels and see this will work just fine
but with sass we can't mix types so the
operation has to be of the same type so
if we're using percentage they all have
to be percentage or they all have to be
pixels so now let's see what that looks
like in the CSS so we have 80% minus 40%
so now we just have the result of that
which is 40%
so if we so if we use the normal CSS
count let's look at what the compiled
CSS looks like so it's gonna go ahead
and pass that entire calculation into
our normal compiled CSS alright so
that's pretty much the basics of sass so
if you want to learn more you can look
at the documentation on sass lang calm
sass is very powerful and once you get
the hang of it it's hard to go back to
normal CSS alright
now let's look at a real world example
so this is what we're going to build a
portfolio website has this cool animated
menu and several pages and the menu
along with the entire website is
responsive and we're going to take a
mobile-first approach when we build this
so here I've got v/s code open and I've
created a project folder on my computer
and then I opened it in vs code and all
that I've done so far is I created a
dist folder along with an image folder
and I just brought in the images that
we'll be using in this project I will
have a link in the description below so
that you can download the project files
as well so in the dist folder let's
start out by creating in index that HTML
file I'm gonna close the sidebar by
pressing ctrl B and now let's start with
our HTML markup so we'll use Emmet
exclamation enter it gives us a
boilerplate and let's title this will
just go with Mike Smith portfolio we're
also going to add our style sheet which
will be created for us from our sass so
we'll add a link and we'll set that to
CSS main dot CSS and the body here we're
going to start out with a header and
then we'll create a div with the class
of menu button and then within here will
create a span with the class of menu
button burger
so the menu button is going to be pure
CSS we're not going to use any images or
fonts for that now within the header
let's create a nav we'll have a class on
that of nav and then we'll create our
menu items so we'll have a ul with the
class of menu nav and then our allies
will have a class of menu nav item all
right now we'll have a link with the
class of menu nav and that is going to
go so our first one will be home so
that's index.html and we'll name that
one home all right so now we're going to
take this Li and we're going to
duplicate it down three times so alt
shift down arrow one two three
so in our home this is the page that
we're on right now so we're going to set
this Li to active and then the next one
will be our about and so we'll say about
me the next one is our projects we'll
say my projects and the last one is our
contact and I will say contact me
we right I think that's it for the
header let's go to our main section now
all right we're gonna start with a main
tag and then we'll have a section and
we'll have a class of home and then
we'll create an h2 and in here we'll say
hi my name is then an h1 with the class
of home name then here we'll put the
name so Mike and then we're gonna have a
span with the class of home name last
and then here we'll put the last name
Smith and then we'll have an h2 and this
will be as titles web developer designer
and programmer
I mean now we're going to add our social
icons we're actually going to put that
in our section still so we'll add a div
with the class of social icons and then
a link and that's not gonna go anywhere
and then we'll add the icon so we're
gonna use um Brittany's font awesome and
I'll show you how to set that up in just
a minute so we're gonna use an icon with
the class of FA B and another class of
FA Twitter and we're also gonna add a
class of FA times - alright and then
let's take these three lines and copy
that down three more times and then
we'll change Twitter to Facebook and
Instagram and github alright and then
after that one last thing is footer and
that's just going to contain our
copyright so we'll do campers and copy
for the copyright symbol and then
copyright whatever you current year is
we're going to have some basic
JavaScript we're going to include a
script the source and the source will be
J s main DJ s alright I think that is it
for the markup so let's look at the font
awesome we also have to add something
here for that all right so this is font
awesomes website and they recently
changed things up a little bit you
actually have to sign up for a free
account so I've already logged in and
I'm just going to go to my kits and
kit that I have and so what we need to
do is to copy this script and put that
into our HTML files so I'm just going to
hit copy code and then we will put that
here alright so I think that is it for
the index.html let's go ahead and save
this and we'll see what this looks like
so I have I have live server installed
so if you just right-click here you can
say open with live server or you can see
there's some shortcut here you can see
that that looks pretty ugly
there's no CSS so okay so let's start
with our sass I'm gonna open the sidebar
by pressing ctrl B and then make sure
that you're in the root and create a
folder s CSS and then within s CSS we're
going to create a file of main dot s CSS
and we're actually going to start with
let's create another file and we'll name
it underscore config dot s CSS so that's
going to be a partial and we're actually
going to create partials for all of our
elements in a large project that's what
you would do you would separate
everything into partials and this isn't
a large project but we're going to go
through that workflow so that you can
see it let me close the sidebar here
control B and our config we're going to
have our variables so we'll have a
primary color and that's going to be a
dark grey and then we'll have our
secondary color and that will be an
orange and then we'll put our resets in
here so box-sizing border-box margin:0
and padding:0 just some standard resets
all right I'm going to save that and
then we'll go to our main CSS and the
first thing we need to do is import
that config so we'll say import config
and we don't have to put the underscore
or the extension alright first let's
let's look at the body and we're gonna
set the background to the primary color
and then we'll set the the text color
for now we'll just set that to a white
we're going to come back to that in a
minute the height would be 100 VH so 100
view height and view view that as a
percentage so basically it's 100% of the
available viewport height I'm going to
change the font family
I like the sagoo and we're gonna set the
line height so one all right now what
we're gonna target our h1 h2 and h3 and
I want the font weight of those to be a
little bit less more normal 400 and then
we've got some links in here so we're
going to target all of the links
globally and we're gonna set the color
to white for now and the text decoration
to none all right and then let's look at
our header so for the header we want it
to have a position of fixed we need it
to always be on top of everything else
so we're going to set a z-index up to a
width of 100% and padding of one rim so
if you're unfamiliar with rim and M
units so Ram units are based on the font
size of the body so the default font
size of the body is 16 pixels and so 1 1
would be 1 times 16 to ram would be 2
times 16
so that would be 32 pixels if we change
the font size of the body to 20 pixels
then one room would be 20 pixels in two
room would be 40 pixels M a.m. it's
pretty much the same thing except it's
not based on the font size of the body
it's based on the font size of the
parent all right so now let's go to our
C main let's target the main here and
we'll set a height of 100 percent and a
width of 100% and then we'll start doing
some nesting let's target our social
icons for that for those I want them to
be position fixed with a bottom so from
the bottom one rim and from the left one
rim within the icons there are links so
let's target those we want a padding on
those of let's say 0.4 m and then on
hover we're going to change the color
we'll set that to our secondary color
lastly we'll target our footer and we'll
set the font size on there to one rim
we're gonna set a fixed position on this
as well because we're going to we want
that to be at the bottom say bottom
point for room and then right one room
I'll do a text align right adding a one
and we'll set the color on that to white
for now
so before we save this unload it we
actually have to initialize our SAS
extension so we're running the live SAS
compiler extension so what we'll do is
we'll hit watch SAS if you don't have V
s code setup I've got a video with the
web dev setup where we walk through the
installation of these extensions and hit
watch SAS
and it opens up an output here and it's
watching and it is compiling our CSS
every time that we hit save and
automatically updated with live server
we go to our files here we can see that
it created a CSS directory and we have
our main CSS here all right so that is
still not looking great let's look at
some CSS that is directly applicable to
the home page so what we're going to do
is we're going to create in this s CSS
folder we're gonna create a new Harshal
and we'll name it home that s CSS
alright so in here we're gonna target
our home class and we're gonna set the
height to 100% put a padding on the top
of 40 VH so again that's like view that
as a percentage forty percent of the
available viewport height we're gonna
set the overflow to hidden we don't want
any scroll bars on the home page it
should always fit we're gonna align
items to the center and we'll do a
text-align:center and then let's set our
background so we're gonna have that
picture and that is URL we need to go up
one level so dot dot slash image slash
and then it was modeled - one dot jpg
and then we're gonna set a background
size to cover alright let's just save
that and see what we have so far oh and
we have to go back to our main and we
have to import that home so import home
save alright so I think the image is
here it's just let's expand this yep so
the image is actually there it's just
not positioned properly yet
so what we're going to do back in our
home on the background we're also going
to set some positioning so we're going
to say Center top that's a little bit
better now the image is too too bright
it's too white so we're gonna put an
overlay on top of it and there's several
ways to do that you could use HTML
markup and then target that and create
an overlay that way you could use pseudo
elements but we're actually going to do
it right here in the background so we're
going to add a linear gradient and then
we're going to say we want the gradient
to go to the right and then we put in
our colors so we're going to use RGB a
and then that takes the first part of it
takes your color so we're going to set
primary color we're going to use that
variable and then we will set this to
0.9 opacity and then we'll do another
RGB a for the second gradient value and
again primary color and we could do 0.9
again and have it the same across but
we're going to set the right side of it
to 0.3 then we need a comma here alright
and you save this there that looks a lot
better make sure that you're still
within the home class and now we're
going to target our underscore name so
this is going to be the home underscore
name the amperes and remember amperes
and always refers to the parent so it's
the same as typing dot home underscore
name okay so we get in here we're gonna
set our font size to five rim we'll set
the padding on the bottom to one rim
margin on the top of one rim and we're
going to set a border on the bottom
and we'll set that to two pixels solid
and for now we're going to set this to
white and then within that name remember
we have a span that goes around the last
name and so that was represent which is
going to be the same as dot home
underscore name - - last and we're going
to set the color on here to the
secondary color and the font weights
we're gonna increase that one up to 700
all right let's save this that's looking
pretty good alright so when we're
hovering over these icons the color just
kind of pops right in so I'm gonna add a
bit of a transition to that so back in
our config let's add a mix in so at
symbol mix in I will name this
transition ease and then we will set a
transition and will set all 0.05 seconds
ease in out okay so normally on the
transition I would target what we're
trying to transition it's the color is
the position what is it here we want to
reuse this so when I include this mix in
I want it to target any transition that
it can set it to a point 5 or half a
second ease in and out alright so let me
save this let's go to our main and we
had a hover in our social icons right
here alright and so let's add the
transition on the link so we'll do to
include the mix and we do include and
then the mixin name transition ease
alright let's save this and now let's
hover over them
you see that it's slowly changing the
color
okay so now let's look here at our
colors we have it set to white but in
our config we have the ability to change
the primary and secondary color so if we
change the primary color to white then
you won't be able to see the text so
what we're going to do in our config is
we're going to create a function that is
going to give us an appropriate color
for our text so to create a function
we'll do at function and this is a lot
like a JavaScript function if you're
familiar with JavaScript so we're going
to set this to set text color and we're
going to pass it a variable of color and
then we're going to use an if statement
so we're gonna say at symbol if and then
lightness we're going to evaluate the
lightness of the color that we're
passing it so if the lightness is
greater than 40% then we're going to
return we'll just we'll set this to
black
all right so if the lightness is greater
than 40% so it means it's a light color
then we want to return a dark color so
black and then we'll do else so if it is
a dark color we want to return white all
right so now we can use this function
instead of declaring the color go back
to our main here so instead of white
we're going to call set text color and
then we're going to pass it our primary
color so it's going to evaluate this
primary color which is dark and it's
going to return us the white value so
anywhere else that we have the color set
we can swap that out so say set text
color primary color
let's see did we set that anywhere else
I think there was one other spot yeah on
the footer
set text color primary there we go we'll
save that nothing's going to change
obviously in now so we also had here on
our border so this line that goes across
in the middle here we're going to set
that as well set text color primary I
think we're good there okay so
everything is looking pretty good except
for our menu of course so let's start to
it let's let's get to work on our menu
so let me open up the sidebar here and
we're going to create a new partial so
underscore menu scss and we'll close the
sidebar and let's see first will target
the menu button we're going to set that
to a position of absolute set the
z-index here to one right one REM and
top one rim okay so we're gonna
absolutely position this so we want this
in the top right corner we'll set the
height to 20 pixels and the width to 28
pixels and when we hover over this we
want a cursor:pointer and we're going to
include our transition mix in so include
transition ease because we're going to
be adding some transition animation to
this
alright so within the menu button we
have our menu button burger so we can do
amperes and underscore burger and this
one we will again position:absolute
we're going to say that this one will be
right zero and top is going to be 0.5
rim the width of 28 pixels height of 3
pixels and the background will be our
set text color and that's going to be
our primary color and again we're going
to include on this one our ease
transition alright and so let's save
this and see what we have and actually
we have to remember back in our main we
have to include this so import that was
menu all right and so now we have a line
so that's just one line and so again
let's look at the HTML so the menu
button is basically a wrapper and we're
using this we're going to be using this
as our click event within the menu
button we're gonna have our bars for the
hamburger we just configured the middle
bar and so we had set it to 28 pixels
wide 3 pixels high and the background
color is going to be the text color
which is going to be white and so now
what we're going to do to create the
other two bars is we're going to use
pseudo elements so within the burger so
we're going to use a ampersand before
and with the pseudo element we have our
content and we'll set that to nothing we
have a position of absolute step the top
2 negative 8 pixels so we want it to
move up 8 pixels from its initial
position and the width
we'll be twenty eight pixels height of
three pixels background color will be
the set text color and we're going to
also include our ease transition okay
and now let's save that and now we have
our top bar alright and so now to add
the bottom bar we're within the Berger
class still so we're going to use
amperes and after and we're basically
going to do the same thing so I'm just
going to copy this and then instead of
eight pixels up we want to go eight
pixels down and I want the bottom bar to
be not the same width so we'll set that
to twenty all right and then let's save
that there we go so now we have our menu
button okay so now on the menu button
we're going to have it animate a bit so
again still within the Berger through
JavaScript we're going to assign it an
open class so when the open class gets
applied to the menu we want it to
transform and we're going to rotate 720
degrees and then we're going to set
background to transparent let's save
this for now and we'll come back to it
let's go ahead and look at the
JavaScript so let me open up the sidebar
and in our distribution folder let's
create another folder name it jf and
then within j/s let's create a file
rename that main j/s all right close the
sidebar let's start by targeting our dom
elements so we'll set some constants
here and we're gonna set the menu button
we'll use document dot query selector
and then here we can query by tag or by
ID or by class so we'll use class here
and menu button was the class alright
and we'll create another constant of
hamburger so the menu button again
that's the basically the wrapper and
then the hamburger is our span so we'll
do a document query selector and that
was a menu menu button burger okay so
then we're going to create a variable
called show menu we're gonna set that to
false so initially the menu is not shown
then we will add an event listener to
the menu button we're going to listen
for the click event and then we will
toggle the menu we'll call this function
that we're going to create here so we're
going to create a function called toggle
menu and so we'll start by saying if not
show menu so the exclamation is a not
operator so if show menu is false then
we're going to get that hamburger class
and we're gonna target the class list
and we're going to add open so we're
going to say that it's now open then
we'll need to set our show menu to true
so now we know that the menu is open and
then we'll put our else statement so if
the menu is open we want
do the opposite right so hamburger
classlist remove open so just the
opposite and then we're also gonna want
to set our show menu back to false all
right so that's it for the JavaScript
for now we'll add a few more lines in a
minute but let's save this and let's see
what it does so there we go it rotates
and the middle line becomes transparent
so if I click it again it should go back
to normal there we go so that is the
first part so the goal is to make that
turn into an X so now what we'll do here
is in our open class we're now going to
target our pseudo elements so we'll do
ampersand before so this is targeting
that top that top bar and we're going to
set the transform rotate to 45 degrees
and we're also going to add a translate
translate moves it and the first value
is going to be your X or your horizontal
position so we want to move it five
pixels over and then the second value is
your Y or your vertical so we want to
move it down eight excells all right
let's just let's save that and see what
we have so far
there we go that's part of our X right
there okay so now let's target our after
so amperes and after that's going to be
the bottom line now remember the bottom
line was a bit shorter so we need to
actually change that so say with 28
pixels make it the same as the top now
and then we will add our transform with
a rotates of this time will be a
negative 45 degrees to make that other
the X and then we will translate this
one to three pixels over and negative
seven pixels and move it up a bit and I
had to play around with these numbers to
get it to work just right but this is
what I came up with so let's save that
and now when I click it we should have
an X there we go all right pretty cool
okay so now we want to show the menu
all right so for the menu let's target
the nav and on that we want the position
to be fixed and the top of zero and the
left of zero width of 100 view it so
with with view width it's the same as
view height so 100 would it be like
saying a hundred percent of the
available viewport width we're gonna set
the opacity to 0.98 so just want to see
a little bit behind it and initially
we're gonna set the visibility to hidden
okay so within the nav we're going to do
the same thing in JavaScript and we're
going to add a class to it so it's gonna
be the same thing we're going to do the
amperes and so it's me nav dot open and
then if it is open we want to change the
visibility to visible still within the
nav let's target our menu nav all right
and then in the main menu nav menu items
the home about me my projects contact me
so we're gonna display those as flex and
then we're going to see flex flow we'll
set that to column and then if for some
reason we have a weird device height
will set this to wrap we're going to
align items center justify content
Center we want the height to be 100 view
height overflow:hidden we don't want any
scroll bars ever on our menu we're gonna
set the background to the primary color
I'll do the list style so let's get rid
of those those bullet points let's do a
padding on the right
to see one rim and then we'll do a
transform and translate actually we're
gonna do a translate y we'll set this to
a negative 100% then we're going to
include our YZ mix in all right so what
this is doing if you're not familiar
with flexbox
I have a video on that as well you can
check it out at my channel so what we're
gonna do on the menu is we have it
translate Y so that is going to be your
vertical and we have a set to a negative
100% so that means the position of the
menu is going to start off the page at
the top and when we click the button we
want it to come in from the top so what
we'll do here is within our menu
navigate sass aynd the open class then
we want to transform translate Y to 0 so
the initial position and we're going to
need to go into our JavaScript add some
more lines here so we need to also
target our nav so that is going to be
document query selector nav and then we
will also need our new menu nav which is
the UL that one's menu nav all right so
we have those and so now we're gonna do
the same thing in here we'll take our
nav class list add open and then our
menu nav
open all right so I'm just gonna take
these copy them down here and we're
gonna change add to remove control D to
select multiple of the same so if I
highlight remove I can control D so and
select all three of them and have three
cursors and it's a good little shortcut
to learn that's it for the JavaScript
for now let's save that and let's see
what we have so now you see that the
menu items are gone so now when we click
on this there we go now we need to
format our actual links here so let's go
back to our menu sass okay so still
within our menu now we're going to see
it was menu nav and ER score item so
we're gonna target each item the menu
itself is coming down from the top but
we want the menu items to come in from
the right so we're going to transform
translate X this time so X is your
horizontal and what the initial value is
going to be 100 view with so we want the
links to be all the way off the right
side of the page we're going to include
our transition mix in and then in
JavaScript we're going to add the open
class just like we did on the others and
when it's open we want to transform
translate X to the initial position so
that we'll bring them in from the right
we're also going to add an active class
to our menu items and then we're going
to target the a the link within and we
want to set the color on that to the
secondary the secondary color and so
that's just going to highlight which
page' currently
and then in the JavaScript we have a
couple more lines to add all right we're
going to add a constant here of nav
items and we'll do document and we can't
do query selector because that selects
one element so we're going to use query
selector all and we're going to get an
array of elements here and that is menu
nav item all right and so then down here
we need to add that we need to add that
open class to these so what we'll do is
we'll do nav items and we'll use a high
order array function we'll do for each
we're going to use an arrow function
here so we're gonna loop through the
items and we're gonna pull each time
we're going to pull one item out and so
in the function will say item class list
dot add open alright so we'll do the
same thing down here except instead of
adding we're going to remove all right
and that should be everything for the
JavaScript now there's nothing else that
we're going to add in here so let's see
what that does now alright that came in
if you could barely see it they come in
pretty quickly from the right but at the
same time that the menu is coming down
so it's not very noticeable so let's add
some more sass to our menu all right so
now make sure that you are within the
menu nav so all right and we're gonna
use ampersand link so it's going to be a
minion a blink we want to display these
inline-block we're going to do a font
size of two REM text transform to
uppercase adding top and bottom of to m0
left and right font weights of 300 and
we're going to include our ease
transition and then on hover we're going
to do a color of secondary color
alright let's save that let's see what
we have now
that looks pretty good but see they're
coming in all at the same time and
they're coming in too quickly
let's go into our menu SAS and then all
the way at the bottom we're going to
include a for loop so very similar to
JavaScript if you're familiar with that
at 4:00 then we're going to declare a
variable I and we're gonna say from 1
through 4 because we have 4 links all
right so now we're going to target our
menu and you nav item and we're going to
target the enth child and we can't just
put the the variable in here you see how
it's highlighting red is telling us that
you can't do that within a function
so we need to wrap this with dollar sign
curly braces so now we've targeted the
enth child so this is going to iterate
through the links so the initial one is
going to target the first link then it's
going to count up one so that it'll be
the second lake the third link the
fourth link so on each link we're going
to do a transition delay and in here we
can use the variable as it is so we're
gonna do the variable times 0.1 seconds
and then we're going to add to that 0.15
seconds I know this is a complicated
formula formula but it's what I came up
with all right so it's going to iterate
through each one and it's going to add a
delay to each one so they should stagger
in alright let's save that and now let's
see what we have there we go
all right so let's look something is a
little bit off here let me go yeah okay
actually here in the whole menu the
margin bottom or the margin should be
margin bottom on the name it's a little
bit off right there so let's save that
there we go that looks much better so
that's gonna be it for the home page so
now let's look at the about page so let
me open the sidebar here and in the
distribution folder we want to add a
file about HTML and let's go ahead and
add the sass file for that as well we'll
add the partial underscore about s CSS
close the sidebar let me close some of
these we don't need the JavaScript
anymore we shouldn't need the menu all
right so let's start with the HTML
markup well we're just gonna begin with
the index.html we'll copy everything
from there paste it into about and let's
say about Mike Smith all right the menu
the now let's take the active off of the
home and we'll put it on the about and
then let's look at our section here
let's change this to about and in this
first part of the section here let's
delete and we'll add a div about bio
image
and then within here we'll have an h2
with the class of text secondary and
we'll say bio so we're gonna add a class
here text secondary so this will be a
reusable class anything that we put it
on will have the secondary color so
let's go ahead and do that let's go to
our main sass file and we'll just put it
right here
we do text secondary and this is just
going to change the color to the
secondary color right and let's just go
ahead while we're in here let's add our
about sass partial right in here let's
add a paragraph and add some lorem in
here thirty now under this we're gonna
have some jobs almost like a small
resume we'll add a div with the class of
jobs another div jobs job so each job so
the first one will say we'll put an H to
the class of text secondary and let's
say 2017 to current and then we'll do it
H h3 we'll say that he works for Google
and then an h6 in his position full
stack developer and then we'll add a
paragraph with some more lorem I put 20
on there let's take this job here and
let's duplicate it two more times so
I'll shift down one two all right so
let's change this one to 2015 to 2017
and let's say that was Microsoft
and let's see front-end developer and
the last one here will say 2012 to 2015
or we'll just make something up web
design Co and we'll say graphic designer
all right then everything else we want
the social icons we want the footer yeah
everything else is the same
okay so let's got all that yep let's
save this let's go into our SAS file all
right we'll start with our about class
let's add a padding on here to the
bottom I'll add two REM and then within
here we have our about bio image here
we'll set the height to 50 view height
the width will be 100% and then we're
going to do the same thing with
background that we did in the home page
here so I'm gonna copy this I'll paste
that there and then on here we'll have a
display as flex and we'll set the Flex
direction to column a line items center
and then justify content we're going to
use flex end okay now still within our
about let's target the paragraph that's
the bio paragraph will set a margin on
the bottom there of two REM alright
let's just see what we have so far we'll
save that alright we'll go to about me
it's already looking pretty good so we
set the view height to 50% we've got the
image back there with the overlay
we've got the title here and the
paragraph displaying is flex set it to a
column and so that we can align Center
and then flex to the end we still got a
bit more to do here we put that this why
does that say block end margin bottom
all right so we put this two round
margin on the bottom so it wouldn't go
all the way to the to the edge actually
here this paragraph should have been
here so we have to be careful with
nesting nesting too much can become an
issue I didn't want to target all of the
paragraphs so I actually missed
something here we forgot to wrap this we
needed to wrap this in and about bio all
right so now let's target on still
within the about let's target the about
bio and we'll set the width here to 80%
and then text-align:center and then I
want to target the text secondary so
that's the the heading I could just
target the heading directly there's many
different ways of doing things but we'll
just target the text secondary and I
want to add a padding on that on the
bottom of one rim alright let's check
that out there that's looking good
alright so now let's style our jobs so
still within about we'll go to jobs and
then within there let's set the width to
60 view with so 60% of the view width
I'll set a margin on here of to rim top
auto write 0 on the bottom bottom left
we're going to display this as grid
we'll set the grid template columns to
initially one fractional unit and then
the grid gap will set two to run so if
you're not familiar with CSS grid I have
a video on that as well check that out
in my channel all right let's see what
we have so far all right looking better
now within jobs we have a jobs job so
each job we're gonna have a background
and we're going to lights and so we're
gonna use the primary color and we're
going to lighten it by 10% then we wanna
padding will add 0.5 REM all around and
then a border bottom will do five pixels
solid and secondary color alright that's
looking good um everything's a little
squished together so within the job here
let's just go ahead and target the
headings directly will say h2 and h3
we'll set those to a margin top and
bottom of 0.5 rim and 0 left and right
on the h6 I'm gonna set the top and
bottom a little bit less so let's go
point 3-0 on left and right there we go
that looks pretty good
alright so now notice the social icons
and the copyright are getting in the way
a bit alright so let's go down here
still within about let's target our
social icons and this time we're going
to display these as flex and we want to
set the Flex direction to column
all right so now they're out of the way
that looks good and we need to do
something with the footer now so let's
target the footer and we're going to
transform we'll start by rotating it
we're going to rotate it 90 degrees and
we're going to translate or move it the
x value will be a negative 3 rim and the
Y value will be a negative 5 rim I had
to play around with these numbers as
well so there you go we flip flipped it
up and put it on its side now it's out
of the way as well all right so that is
it for this page we'll get into the
responsiveness once we're finished with
all of our pages all right so now let's
move on to our projects page so let me
open the sidebar and in this let's add
another file and this is going to be
projects HTML and then let's go ahead
and add our sass file as well the
partial underscore projects dot s CSS
all right close the sidebar and now what
we'll do here is let's just use the
about let's copy everything from there
into projects and then we'll modify it
alright so we'll say Mike Smith projects
and let's take the active here and let's
put it on the projects link
all right so let's rename this to
projects and I'm actually going to have
the image in here as well so let's
rename this to projects bio image and
then within the bio image I will delete
this we'll add an h1 with a text
secondary class and we'll say my
projects alright and then let's get rid
of the jobs here
alright so now here let's put a div with
the class of projects items should be
projects projects items and then
projects item alright items and then
item this time we're going to use an
image and the source is going to be
image and then project one for the alt
so I'll just put my project
all right under this we're going to have
a div with the class of projects
projects buttons all right so we're
gonna have an overlay over these and
there's going to be some buttons within
the overlay so in here let's add a link
the class of projects button and that's
just not that's not going to go anywhere
and then we'll put an icon here and it's
going to be FAS F a I
oops not gas FAS alright and then after
that let's say
preview all right and then let's take
this link and we're going to alt shift
down arrow copy it we want to links here
this one is going to be instead of I
it's going to be github and actually any
since it's a brand we have to change to
FA B for brand and let's change this to
github alright so that is one project so
let's highlight this and we're going to
duplicate it we have six total projects
so we're going to duplicate it five
times alt shift down arrow one two three
four five alright let's go back up to
the first one alright here's the first
one and all we're going to change on
these is the the project image
everything else will stay the same so
two three four five and six
alright and then everything after that
the social icons the footer everything
else would be the same so let's save
this let's go ahead and check that out
it's going to look ugly I don't know
yeah okay can't really tell what's going
on there so let's go to our SAS and the
SAS here is going to be pretty close to
what's in the about CSS one for the most
part the top part anyway so let's just
copy this and we'll make some
adjustments alright so this is going to
be projects padding-bottom to around
this good image this time I want it to
be a 30 view height background all of
that's good flex columns Center flex and
all of that's good so here's where
things will change up a bit we'll take
the paragraph out we're going to target
the text secondary and I want the font
size to be a bit bigger set it to 2m
and I want the margin on the bottom to
rim all right and then we don't need
this
alright so here a lot of this is the
same so we'll change jobs to projects
items so that's the wrapper
all right so let's take the let's take
this part out and then we also have
projects item so on the item we're gonna
set the position to be relative because
we're going to need to absolutely
position other items we're going to set
the boarder bottom to five pixels solid
and the secondary color we want the
overflow to be hidden and talk about
that in a minute
cursor:pointer now within here we have
the image and we want the width on those
to be 100% right now they're way off the
page all right let's um let's stop there
and let's see what we have well I keep
forgetting in our main sass we need to
import that so let's import our projects
save and that looks much better
alright let's get back over here to our
sass file so that's looking okay we're
gonna do something with these buttons
now let's go in here and we're gonna
create an overlay this time we're going
to use a pseudo element so we're going
to use this is the projects item and
then create an after we have our content
we'll set that to blank position here is
going to be absolute that's why we have
the apparent container set to relative
all right we're gonna initially set the
top at 100% so that is gonna push it all
the way to the bottom initially it's
going to be under its element and so
that's the reason why we set the
overflow to hidden that way we don't see
it because when we hover we want it to
pull up from the bottom all right
where's that left to zero set the height
to 100% and the width to 100% we're
going to set the background to the
secondary color and opacity initially
initially is going to be zero and let's
include our transition alright that's
looking good now that's really not gonna
do anything and we'll save it you'll see
it really looks the same because that
item is hidden so let's create a hover
event here so this is gonna be the item
that's ampers an hover and what we're
gonna do is on hover we need to target
the pseudo element so that's gonna be
after we want the top to be zero instead
of 100% so it's gonna put it back where
it should go and the opacity I want to
set it to point zero nine I just want to
barely see through it all right so let's
save that now if we hover over it there
we go it comes up from the bottom and
becomes visible all right so now we
still have these buttons to deal with
okay so this so we're still in the item
all right and what we need is projects
buttons so projects is the main so we're
gonna have to come down here and make
sure that we're not under the item we're
under the projects so amperes and
buttons here we're gonna set a position
of absolute on the top is going to be
zero height of 100% width of 100% we're
gonna set a z-index of one we're going
to display these as a grid so let's do
our grid template columns
and these will always be in a two column
layout so we want the preview to be on
the left and the github to be on the
right so we're going to use repeat I'm
going to say repeat twice one fractional
unit so that will make them equal and
we're going to align items to the center
and text-align:center
okay let's save that and now they're
there but I only want them to pop up
when I hover let's target the individual
buttons now so projects button here
we're going to set the opacity to zero
initially I'm going to set the color to
the set text oops
set text color based on the secondary we
want to base it off to the secondary
because that's what's going to be behind
it all right and then let's include our
transition and now we need a hover so
campers and hover on hover I want the
text color to change so we're going to
say color and let's see we can do can do
this on orange I think that's going to
return a white but when I hover over I
wanted to change the black just to show
that that I'm hovering over it
and so I want it to be the opposite so I
know that this is white so I can kind of
a hack but I can do I can wrap that in
another set text color and so that's
going to set the text color against
white which is going to be black now
what we need to do is I want the button
to display when I hover over the project
item so in order to do that I have to go
to the project item here and we'll go to
our hover event and after the
pseudo-element will do projects button
and then we'll change the opacity to 1
all right let's save that let's see what
we have okay the hover is not working
why is this set to column rolled color
sorry about that
all right let's see okay it was opposite
all right so initially this is black and
when I hover over it it changes to white
for the social icons on the footer there
great we're gonna leave them just like
that all right that's all looking good
so now let's look at the contacts page
let me pull out the sidebar and under
dist let's create contact dot HTML let's
go ahead and create our SAS partial
underscore contact dot s CSS all right
let's go ahead and in the main let's go
ahead and add that before I forget
and that was contact alright let's just
let's use the project's HTML we'll copy
that we'll paste that in the contact
and we'll say contact Mike Smith all
right and then let's change our active
here to our contact link change our
section class to contact and then
everything within here we can go ahead
and remove so we're going to add an h2
and we're just gonna say contact me all
right and then let's add a div with the
class of contact list and then we'll add
a div with the class of contact contact
email within here we'll have an icon FAS
FA and Volokh and then we'll just say
email there then we'll have a div with
the class of text secondary and within
here we'll put the email so we'll just
say email and email calm all right so
let's copy this down twice all right so
we have an email we also have a phone
that's going to be mobile alt say phone
and this just put a number in here there
we go and then this last one is going to
be address and for that we'll use the
icon marker alt and say we'll say
address and then just put a generic
address one two three
first streets Houston Texas all right
everything else past here we're gonna
keep the same all right
let's save that let's go to the contact
page it's gonna be ugly
there we go all right so let's go to our
contact SCSS so from here this one's
gonna be a lot like home so let's just
copy all of this from home into here
change this to contact all right so
we're gonna have a view height of 100%
padding on the top 40 view height okay
so here we're going to change this we're
gonna display this as flex and we're
going to set the Flex direction to
column background is good we're going to
use that same thing alright and so then
everything after this we can take that
out so here we're going to target the h2
and we're going to set the font size to
3 rum and margin-bottom
to two rum and then we're going to
target the contact contact list we're
going to display this as grid so get our
grid template columns and initially it's
going to be set to one fractional unit I
want a grid gap to run and we're going
to change the font lips we're going to
change the font size to 1.5 rim alright
and then yeah let's let's say that see
what we have alright that's looking okay
so far let's see I think I missed
something here flex column yeah we need
to align items Center there we go
so that is all of the pages let's go
through we've got our main page here and
then our about me and projects looking
good alright and then the contact
actually you know what I want to do on
the contact I want to change the social
icons I want them to be up here so right
here let's do social icons let's change
the position to initial and we'll set a
margin top on there of to around yeah I
like that better it's all in the same
spot to contact and next we'll make this
responsive all right let's see what this
looks like before we make any responsive
changes actually doesn't look terrible
but obviously we don't want to have this
menu when we're at this size let's see
the other pages that actually doesn't
look terrible either but we'll make a
few changes here maybe make this text
bigger and let's check out projects oh
yeah that's that's too big you know
we'll need to adjust that grid and and
we'll make these in line instead of
stacked all right so the first thing
that we need to do is we'll go to our
config in our sass file and we will go
and then at the bottom we're going to
include some mix-ins
so at Mixon and we're going to create a
mix and for for some media queries so
we'll start with a medium sized and so
we're going to include in this mix in a
media screen
and let's it will put a minimum width of
768 and then in here we will put at
content so now when we call this mix in
whatever content will be will get passed
into this media query all right so
that's for the medium size let's go
ahead and just copy this down alt shift
down we're going to create two more so
we're going to create a large and that
is going to be 1024 pixels and then
we're gonna create an extra-large and
that will be anything over 1600 pixels
all right and I'll save this and let's
start with let's just go back to the
home page here so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna create a new sass file I'm
gonna name it underscore responsive dot
F CSS all right and then let's go to our
main s CSS and let's include that there
we go
save that so now in our responsive we're
going to include our media queries those
mix-ins
so we're going to include media medium
we'll start with the smaller smaller
sizes and then work our way up so start
with the menu so menu button at this
size we want the visibility to be hidden
and then our nav I want the visibility
of this to be visible and then within
the nav we have our menu navigation
because we don't want the full page nav
to come up we want a nav bar at the top
so let's change this display here to
block by default it's fixed
and then we're gonna transform and
translate why because we had that all
the way at the top so now we need to put
it back in its place and then let's set
a height here to 100% that is available
to it set the background currently it
has the dark grey back around the
primary color so we're going to set that
to transparent and then we're going to
text the line to the right then within
here we have our items so that is menu
nav item and we need to display these in
line all right and then we're going to
add a padding on the right of 1.5 mm
then we need to target the menu link
then on the link we're going to change
the font size because we we made it
bigger earlier so by default I think it
was three round so we're gonna change it
to 1.5 mm let's see what we have so far
we'll save that all right now let's
check it out so we get over 768 there we
go nice that looks good back all right
let's see what we need to do on the
about page I think we'll just make this
text a little bit bigger as we go yeah
okay so outside of so we're still inside
the media the medium media query or
outside of the nav so we're gonna add an
about bio and then let's change the font
size to 1.5 REM make it just a little
bit bigger all right let's see and that
looks good
yep alright let's look at the projects
so it's one column there and then yeah
we're going to want to change that
so let's target projects and then within
the projects I think it was the bio
image
yeah the heights on there because let's
see when we get yeah it's getting a
little too close I think so let's change
the height so I think it was 50
initially so let's go 40 view height and
then projects items let's change the
grid templates columns and we're going
to change that to a repeat two of one
fractional unit all right and then this
my projects would probably need to
increase that a bit so that was say we
could target the text secondary and
we'll change the font size there to
three rim alright let's save that and
see what we have yeah that's that looks
good all right I don't think there's
anything I'll say let's go to contacts
yeah so let's let's make this - lets add
contacts contact list and what the grid
template columns and we'll do the repeat
to 1fr on that one as well
alright let's see yeah that's good
alright so that is on medium screens so
let's move on to the large screens a
couple of things that we're gonna change
here so let's include that mix in media
query so include media large I think
projects yeah let's let's make projects
let's turn projects into a three column
at a large layout so let's see where was
that we could take this paste it here
get rid of the bio image and close that
out and change this to a three that
should work I'll save it
alright medium-sized to large size three
yeah that's good
alright and then let's do the same thing
for the contact let's change that to
three so I'll just copy this put it
there and change that to three save it
to there we go that looks pretty good
that looks good
alright and then the last part let's see
let's go to projects so right in this
area the image is getting too close so I
want to increase the height on this on
an extra large screen so let's go to our
last mix in that's the large media query
so let's include it's the extra-large
and so let's hear that was a projects
bio image and then let's change the
height to 50 VH there we go that looks
good all right and then let's see we
could make this have a fourth column
possibly but I think it looks good
so let's go through it real quick we've
got the main screen looks good on a big
screen
and go down to a small screen looks good
as well we have our menu right let's go
to our about me that looks good let's go
to a larger screen now I could take
these and turn them into columns as well
but I like the way that they're stacked
because of the years so the current is
on top and then it goes down so I'm just
going to leave this as a column I think
it looks better and then projects we
already looked at that that looks good
and then contact so that that looks good
as well
nice
all right so let's talk about deploying
this so we're gonna deploy this today on
github pages and we could also use net
liffe I that's another good one but I
went ahead and uploaded the project to
github and if you're not familiar with
git and github I have a video on that as
well you can check out in my channel but
it's very simple so I've got this
uploaded and we're gonna go to settings
and then if you just scroll down to the
github pages portion I just set this to
the master branch
alright let's scroll back down and now
it says your site is ready to be
published so we could set a custom
domain if we want I'm just gonna leave
the default there so now if we go here
and go to dist
there we go so this is live on the
internet now so that's going to be it
for this video if you stuck around to
the end thank you for watching
alright so before you go if you like
this video a thumbs up is appreciated I
upload new content every week so hit
subscribe in the Belle to get notified
if you think this video or any of the
videos on my channel might be helpful to
someone else please share them i'm also
on twitter and instagram at code stacker
thanks for watching